there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
february to test for ourselves i haven't
tried a hard candy product since i was a
kid but this glitter palette blew up on
tick-tock this is the glitteratsi
glitter eye palette in glitz and cheer
the glitter is not loose it does have
some sort of sticky base that holds it
together and makes it really easy to
glide on i was honestly blown away by
how pigmented these glitters are i used
my fingers to apply it to my eyes these
top two shades do that thing where
depending on what angle your face is at
the glitter disappears and reappears
it's so magical and pretty i will say
that i did get glitter fallout so i'd
recommend using another glitter base to
make sure that doesn't happen but i had
fun playing around with this palette if
you're someone who's into glitter i
highly recommend it fenty beauty just
came out with the icon semi-matte
refillable lipstick so the case and the
actual lipstick are sold separately and
then you assemble them together i'm not
going to lie it took me a minute to
figure out but i did eventually i got
the shade the mvp which is another
universal red from fenty that's supposed
to look good on every skin tone the
shape of the lipstick was actually
inspired by rihanna's iconic cupid's bow
and i actually found it really easy to
sort of map out my lip line with it
since i didn't apply any lip liner
before the pigment is incredible and
totally full coverage it's just a very
creamy formula that feels so smooth and
hydrating on the lips i can't even
believe this is semi-matte it's
definitely not transfer proof but i was
actually really impressed by how it
looked after i kissed my hand clearly so
much product came off but the lipstick
still looked incredible it is
interesting to see regular lipstick
releases in the age of mask wearing but
this formula is excellent nars has a new
foundation formula the light reflecting
advanced skincare foundation nars knows
how to do complexion products so well
and it has a huge hit with this i've
actually been using this for weeks now
and i'm completely in love with it the
foundation is so lightweight on the skin
it feels like you're not even wearing
foundation the coverage is on the light
to medium side but i definitely think
you can build it up without it getting
cakey the finish is so nice it makes
your skin look really fresh and dewy
without looking oily and all of my other
products layer on top of this foundation
really well kvd beauty released its good
apple lightweight full coverage
concealer the name had me so intrigued
because usually full coverage products
can get heavy on the skin and my under
eyes are so picky about what concealer
they like i immediately love this
applicator shape it picks up a good
amount of product and the shape makes it
easy to apply i could tell from testing
it out on the back of my hand that it
actually does feel way more lightweight
than i expected but it covers really
well i applied it everywhere i normally
apply concealer let it all sit for a
second and then started blending this
concealer blends like a dream it just
melts into the skin without losing any
coverage i did add a little more on my
under eye area just for some extra
brightening and it layered beautifully
no problems there and then i set it all
with a powder and i think it still
looked really good while feeling super
light on the face the name did not lie
colourpop released these adorable
heart-shaped pressed powder blushes just
in time for valentine's day they kept
selling out but i managed to get this
bright coral shade called forever yours
these blushes look deceptively matte in
the pan but if you look at my finger
swatch it's definitely got a pretty
sheen which i love this blush was so
unbelievably pigmented i tapped my brush
off before i applied it and it still
went on this intensely but i went back
in with a clean brush to tone it down
and it looked so much better this blush
formula is really silky and pretty plus
a little goes a really long way so i
love this also i am a sucker for
anything heart-shaped carla cosmetics is
a totally new brand for me and i've been
dying to try its shadow potion gel
eyeshadow it's this multi-chrome gel
eyeshadow i swatched it on my hand first
and this texture isn't something i've
really tried before i just went in with
my fingers and did gentle tapping
motions it does dry quickly but not so
quickly that you don't have time to work
with it it definitely showed up as more
pinky purple on my eyes with olive green
on the outer corners that multi-chrome
shift depends on the lighting so i think
it looked more obvious away from direct
sunlight
milk makeup recently released this rise
mascara i actually love their kush
mascara so i was really excited to try
this
and then i actually tried it this is
just so
average it took me three layers for it
to give my lashes any sort of lift and
even that effect was subtle i've tried
drugstore mascaras that have done a lot
more for a lot less this is the mini
size and it was 14 bucks i will say i
did love the packaging this material
kind of feels like a pencil grip and i
love that the actual mascara not so much